voilà un sondage qui ne va pas faire
plaisir à tout le monde et qui ne va pas
arranger notre image aux yeux du monde
selon une étude menée par l'ifop pour le
parisien en france nous sommes loin
d'être irréprochable côté propreté
si c'est un cliché qui circulent sur nos
à l'étranger ce récent sondage semblent
confirmer la tendance ont fondé son
sondage l'institut s'est focalisée sur
plusieurs critères comme la toilette
quotidienne le changement de sous
vêtements ou encore le lavage de mains
et en ce qui concerne la toilette visage
et corps 71% des hommes l'effectuent
tous les jours contre 80% des femmes
du côté des sous-vêtements l'écart se
creuse en ce qui concerne leurs
changements quotidiens 6 94% des femmes
changent chaque jour de sous-vêtements
seulement 73 % des hommes en font autant
à noter un chiffre inquiétant 1 % des
sondés ont déclaré nous l'échangé qu'une
fois tous les quinze jours enfin dernier
chiffre flora goûtant seuls 71 % des
français se laverait les mains après
être allé aux toilettes est seulement
49% avant de passer à table
bref une véritable douche froide pour
les français alors on a dix questions
pour le docteur frédéric saldmann kate
avec nous on n'est jamais mentionné que
par soi même décidé de poser des
questions sur l'hygiène et on sait que
ça vous intéresse et juste après je vous
poserai une question sur le corona virus
que je crois qu'on a des infos qui
viennent d'allemagne qui ne sont pas
réjouissantes ni ragoûtantes
bonjour déjà frédéric merci bonjour vous
êtes un petit peu chez vous ici un
ensemble vous venez à chaque fois bah
écoutez on se sent bien ici tout va bien
ici les gens sont propres sauf sauf deux
à vous de les détectives à doit-on
nécessairement se laver une fois par
jour c'est mieux une fois par jour de se
laver ouais surtout s'il fait chaud si
on a de l'activité c'était beaucoup plus
mais est-ce que si on se lave pas par
exemple voilà pendant un jour cesser ces
grades complice est imbattable
je vais revenir sur un sujet il ya des
zones intimes qu'il faut s'abonner à
cesser chez tous les jours lesquels
plusieurs jeunes n'ont eu qu'un exemple
le cul de mater fessiers le poids le
site aussi ce n'est pas moi n'y a qu'à
le sua mercier de france on utilise du
papier ce qui est pas terrible nation
lingettes talent la jette ou s'abonner à
ses saisines est à dire mais la
savonnette on se la met
[Rires]
il ya 40% des français qui ont des
problèmes avec leur anus et des pas sûrs
d'eux à 40 enfants
alors bien sûr difficile et un deux
trois
c'est toi c'est toi c'est toi c'est toi
aussi là bas c'est très fragile c'est
comme la peau qu'on a sous les yeux
même si bien que le papier dessus c'est
pas terrible du tout ça il reste des
matières mais pas du caca sur le braille
sécher santé appelle problème bien sûr
il y aura toujours du caca sur l'autre
ça finit par être pas tu étais donc si
on s'abonne pas une fois par jour donc
alors donc avec constitué de qq le mieux
mama cool avec la même directement la
main de l'amitié mais le mieux c'est de
prendre une douche ça peut leur
complétion plus on se cale dans un
restaurant des lingettes ou pas si on
peut pas si ya pas de douche les achète
c'est pas mal des lingettes
voilà exactement non mais c'est plein de
perturbateurs endocriniens avoir le la
nuit sans chou-fleur pas possible non
mais c'est vrai exactement mais c'est
vrai avoir mal à l'anus ça c'est un
super chiant moi j'ai un trophée
japonais mais bien ils sont encore un
petit peu a fait dire que pas omettre
des sushis avec la brosse service est
bon alors mais c'est important donc ça
c'est une idée reçue
donc voilà je vous le dis il faut pas se
laver tous les jours si gros on n'est
pas du tout les choses il faut pas
oublier les parties intimes les
aisselles les doigts de pied et voilà
qu'on ait autant l'avait l'ensemble oui
quoi il ya tous les gynécos oui j'ai tu
peux en témoigner nous disent qu'il faut
pas se laver la géniale tous les jours
mais qu'il faut juste la rincer à l'eau
moi c'est oui je les ai jamais med
savons là dans le bain non faut pas à
ses abonnés le relâche est énormément le
levage hsa four autonettoyant un accord
des frais je parlais de la brosse et
pyrolyse
une flore était pas dire qu'elle donnera
pas la perturber et les lèvres est ce
qu'on met du savant non mais oh et
laissera une lèvre bombe a coûté 2 et
moi on est où là avait dit lui qu'il
faut qu'elle se lève à l'extérieur oui à
l'extérieur avec du savon à neutre ph
et là et merci alors que j'ai souri mais
c'est vrai ce que l'excès d'hygiène et
dangereux ça vous inquiétez pas isabelle
vous n'êtes pas vrai ce que l'excès
d'hygiène et dangereuse oui si on
vraiment cela fait toute la journée
c'est pas près tout sauf les mains
d'accord par sciemment donné le film
lipidique de la peau va être un peu
fragilisé d'accord à oui c'est vrai donc
une fois par jour c'est bien moi j'aime
bien le lavage le soir d'accord parce
que on se débarrasse en même temps
d'épaulement en état polluants dans la
journée à corps et c'est très bien
avant d'aller au lit cela se laver dans
là pour enlever les polluants 3ds qu'il
faut obligatoirement changer de sous
vêtements tous les jours oui surtout
parce que ça donne des problèmes de
convivialité à ya beaucoup d'amour
ils portent des slim noir par manque de
confiance en ont fait ça exactement ou
parce qu'il ne change pas souvent mais
surtout pas castaldi passe pour réciter
les versets oui les blancs mais c'est
évident que quand on était blanc dans
lequel on transpire qui macèrent sa
venue et des rougeurs au niveau de la
terre cuisse et puis au niveau de la
région anale c'est pas terrible non il
faut préciser son anus quoi d'autres
voient pas les retourner vu le début
samedi de la té m il a raison mais c'est
important la ligier nos parce que vous
avez vu ce qui est dit 1 et francis sont
sales dont une française aux salles est
ce que c'est
les français sont sales c'est ce qu'on
ne naît pas les champions du monde la
propre t n'ont plus vraiment non parce
que je vous le dis 73 % des hommes
chances de ce type tous les jours donc n
27 qui changent pas de ce type tous les
jours voilà qu'ils retournent voilà oui
oui vous dire que ça va oui mais moi
j'avais un copain on faisait ça gardant
un style 4 facile
on l'a fait on l'appeler le rugby stade
21 % des hommes changent de slick deux
fois par semaine 4 % des hommes changent
une fois par semaine à % des hommes
changins tous les quinze jours et un
pour cent des jeunes n'en porte pas
c'est souvent tracas jean-michel gentil
voilà yami et les chipayas même les
opinions politiques et les
sous-vêtements il ya eu un relâchement
sondage qui a été fait 44% des électeurs
de françois fillon fait rien a plus
maintenant ne change pas de slip tous
les jours 28% des électeurs d'emmanuel
mac on ne change pas de slip tous les
jours 22 % des électeurs de mélenchon ne
sens pas de signes chaud les électeurs
les plus propres ce sont les électeurs
de benoît hamon
puisqu'il n'y en a pas eu voilà il est
clairement de ces sondages 1% les
électeurs de marine le pen ne change pas
de slip tous les jours je vous le dis
maintenant alors bureaux de vote
d'aujourd'hui c'est vrai alors question
suivante est-ce qu'il est dangereux de
ne pas porter de sous-vêtements
ce qui nous a tout d'abord il ya un
accident qu'on voit de temps en temps
aux urgences c'est quoi ces des hommes
qui portent pas de slip mais il remonte
la moyenne des prêts verguet ce mois çi
ces camps est tu te coincer
il ya des enquêtes à l'esa et donc mais
à la bouquetière montre et c'est comme
je suis avait un truc ici ouais c'est
comme tel et une boule de feu une boule
de baby-foot arriver à nourrir en plus
quand on change pas de slip et que le
pantalon fait à moi oui l'état du
pantalon seat audi a reserré à bas le
pantalon il tient tout seul après ça
mais je sais c'est fou hadopi soit il
faut mettre des sous vêtements je vous
le dis voilà comment on vous donne des
conseils
oui c'est important est-ce que l'on peut
porter un vêtement que l'on vient
d'acheter alors il faut mieux le laver
avant parce qu'il ya énormément de
produits chimiques et on va transpirer
c'est inutile de se faire un bain de
produits chimiques noyau par mois c'est
rich man quand on achète un truc qu'on a
envie de le porter tout mais non mais
c'est comme quand tu rencontres une meuf
envie de la pêche tout de suite c'est
vrai maintenant jeu pareil tu auras ta
pas envie d'attendre
d'avancé merci isabelle merci à mieux
vous l'avez un string c'est mieux bah
oui mais bon j'ai achètera le monde
était très léger j'ai complètement
arrêté un voile à supporter ses
sous-vêtements taux moyen beau oui bien
chiant d'accord sleeping tension -
jallet barbare et qu'on assure toi c'est
la bonne nouvelle les chéri e
il faut se laver les mains comme un deux
fois par jour en sortant des toilettes
pas normalement oui oui mais un sur deux
le fait pas non et surtout quand on
serre la main de quelqu'un qui n'est pas
qui sort des toilettes avec des massages
comme on se met deux fois parole et ma
bouche on retrouve les germes fécaux
dans sa bouche
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on a
du cac à coquelles dans la bouche dans
la bouche non mais quelle horreur
ça veut dire le caca et l'a déjà sur la
personne a pris vient là après il vient
là après toi tu vas gallo chine l'hôte
haka après la meuf va te tromper elle va
galocher un autre mec tu auras le 4k
doute mais sans rigoler c'est un truc de
ouf ça veut dire tu vas te retrouver
avec un mec que tu connais pas ta du
caca d'un mec qui connaît pas ou c'est
non c'est un imbroglio ingenico non mais
je crois docteur il faut se laver les
mains à rossi avant l'arrivée en france
ont donc on a sa table il faut toujours
se et main avant de toucher on met des
germes qui n'ont rien à faire dessus
allez donc se laver les mains avant
c'est la fois les importations changé
pour les femmes pour les hommes
les indics robe n'oubliez jamais un
microbe ça saute
exactement comme ça saute c'est comme
une question sérieuse ou pas sur wii je
croyais docteur que la plupart des
microbes qui était à l'air libre
moore est à 90% des microbes à l'air
libre ou rem non pas du tout non non la
plante au delà je vous dis les chéris
les gels hydro-alcooliques
est-ce qu'ils sont dangereux sont pas
dans choix ça peut être utile mais
attention il s'agit pas bénir ses mains
en en mettant un petit peu il faut
frotter nadal a frôlé la relégation les
ongles et son et son que c'est tellement
important
brossez vous les ont tous les soirs
avant d'aller au lit
c'est beaucoup mieux parce que les virus
les bactéries adore se mettre sous les
ongles et si vous avez un rapport sexuel
s'est vite d'ensemencer le vagin des
microbes avec les angles sinon à la
personne par accoucher d'un microbe
oui tout simplement bien entendu je
connais un petit peu
non mais c'est vrai je connais je
connais oui oui docteur ès qu'il faut se
laver après avoir fait l'amour
bah alors ça dépend avec qui après away
c'est utile parce que sinon il peut y
avoir des germes qui remonte c'est
d'éliminer ça c'est une bonne idée a
voulu se laver après c'est pas
nécessaire par contre ce qui est pièces
de dormir après une petite cuillère
pendant un quart d'heure à cuire ça
prolonge on peut tomber en fonction
d'accords andorran petite cuillère après
avoir fait l'amour il faut avoir fait
pipi poupée poutou et les chercher car
faut-il faire le français on va parler
des frontons du ménage ce qu'il faut
faire le ménage tous les jours c'est une
bonne idée parce que tout simplement
sinon d'avoir des microbes dans la
maison il ya des microbes et à la
pollution aussi bien sûr donc d'aérer le
leader et la maison les horaires non
respect des horaires prémunir contre le
goya lemoine toiture possible dans la
rue c'est bien parce que c'est une
question chérie fm ça qu il ya moins de
voitures qu'à moins de pollution peau
faut aérer c'est très important et le
ménage c'est beaucoup mieux parce que
sinon on vit avec
au bout de deux ans 10% du poids d'un
oreiller seppois des acariens mort ou de
leurs déjections
non non les actions ora i d'égérie wii
et sa carrière oui ici un à carnières
fait que gm car il ya un mort benji tout
simplement parce que les à bout de 2 ans
et 10 % le poids de l'oreiller il faut
changer les options nous allons changer
de l'oreiller où il fait un navet
laurier d'oreiller est-ce qu'on peut
laver des acariens volos leur dire tu
avec des sacs
vêtue ces deux bateaux au congélateur
sénateur va écouter
moi je voudrais que mon slip et à la
même température que j'ai inscrits très
très froid vont pas porter des cibles
trop serré des lieux à moi c'est ce que
je fais c'est vrai ton problème ça vous
avez raison non parce que les bourses
ont un degré en dessous pour que ça
reste au frais ouais parce que sinon
c'est possible je peux m'en remettre
mais bourse directement pré triche pas
j'aime récupère le soir s'ils ont certes
trop il passe à 37 et c'est pas bon pour
la fin une a pour sa part donné sa
dépendance est ce que les éponges avec
lequel on fait le ménage sont
dangereuses qu'on entend toujours ça on
dit que les éponges s'est plaint de
bactéries ou c'est un nid à bactéries
c'est un taudis à microbes parce que
c'est de l'humidité un peu de chaleur
ils ont le temps de se multiplier à fond
donc l'épongé face à cela je suis tout
le temps de ménage moi et chaque fois je
suis angoissé l'allaitement d'une éponge
c'est comme le gant de toilette c'est
usage unique
ah oui on s'en sert et on menait aux
salles vous que parce que moi ma mère
avant elle acheté des gants de paulette
nous c'est les grandes polémiques unis
c'est à dire le gant de toilette frère
tu veux mais sur ta peau frère s'est pas
tu te brosses et pas pourquoi tes
preuves parce que tu as plus de peau
ferme du sauna douche tes propres mettez
en scène mon frère c'est ces gens là
pour faire ma mère quand j'étais petit
elle me donnait la douche mon frère
c'est moins bien mais je sortais mon
frère j'étais grippé de partout on a vu
le résultat
on dirait que je dormais tête bêche avec
isabelle morini-bosc ses griffes non
mais c'est un truc de malade et fou faux
scoop est souvent les ondes de hbo a
c'est très important parce que les oh là
là des ondes de rmc une télécommande est
peu changée
sur la tête de ma mère elle mais sont
viables sur le toit en catégorie 6 la
netflix direct a même pas besoin de
payer mon cas à la des oeuvres à la des
glo mon frère c'est un truc de fou rire
les bleus ont fait récemment encore
c'est un truc d'où elle a des centaines
au bouddhisme ya darty qu'il n'y en ait
pas alors il faut se découper ça allait
oui c'est mieux parce que façon les
microbes pouvaient se mettre sous les
ongles et le vernis mais il ya des
schtroumpfs voter